talk to us a bit about how you've gone
about and i'm sure there's been plenty
of good days and bad days yeah but how
have you gone about juggling being steph
the mum yeah when you walk through the
door at home to
being someone that's driven money hungry
and have to perform at work as well with
clear
huge responsibilities on your shoulders
yeah i think one of the things is that
in my eyes i didn't give myself a choice
okay it was that i was so determined to
build a career that was successful and i
think that a lot of people when i was
growing up
and found out that i was pregnant and
stuff and i was having a leo at quite a
young age that didn't believe in what i
was going to be able to achieve and were
like yeah you're probably just going to
you know go on to benefit yeah and not
get a job or not finish uni and i think
because of that i was really just
committed to or i guess a little bit
proven them wrong yeah it could be quite
stubborn and i think secondly like when
you're going through that you just
her needs a number one so making sure
that you've got you're organized that
you have a routine like i probably don't
know how to sit still now because
it was it's you're constant you're
constantly you're going you're going
going and so people will say to me now
like i just you don't want to chill out
but but i do but i have probably
different things that i do to chill out
now because she's 13 now so it's like
she's like self-sufficient but i think
when she was a baby and it was like
doing recruitment i think it was it it
was just and i still i still had a
social life i still did other stuff it
wasn't like that was the only thing i
did like live and breathe recruitment
and have her i think it was just being
able to make sure that like i was
organized like everything was sorted and
there were days when that didn't go to
plan and that you would have to adapt
and you'd have to work stuff out but it
was always okay it was not like i was
ever in a situation where really i
probably couldn't go to work or there
wasn't flexibilities at work definitely
because i had to start at seven so that
was hard and i broke up with my partner
so that made it difficult but
there's always a solution there was
never a time where
i was like i'm giving up because that's
what it really is like yes it's hard it
is hard you've decided to have a child
so that is your responsibility so now
it's your responsibility to make that
happen and still build your career and
if people don't
in my opinion
there's never really a strong enough
reason
besides the fact that you decided that
you're not going to do it the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored by vincerie and the
award-winning sauce breaker